many children getting their first bike
is a very big deal it's an early
opportunity for independents but when it
comes to kids with disabilities some
cannot ride a bike for a whole variety
of reasons for our series a more perfect
union janet chameleon shows us how a
louisiana man is working to give all
children that sweet taste of freedom
for kyah roach distance is measured in
the smallest of
it increments with cerebral palsy and
epilepsy crawling is her only
independent mobility at four years old
what has this been like for you um it's
been hard knowing that she may never be
able to walk and be like the other
children but
she's still kind
and that's all that matters to me amanda
roach is decidedly positive
move your feet
let's roll she'd love for kaya to take
part in activities like her friends i'm
hoping one day she'll get there what
mother and daughter are about to
discover one day is today okay we'll
tighten up a few things louisiana
retiree andrew mclinden is surprising
kaya with an adaptive bike
specially built for her unique needs in
this case an extra wheel and straps to
help keep her upright look at that
look at that
it's the 430th he's donated after
gifting the first one to a family friend
13 years ago the neighborhood kids
thought this bike was the coolest thing
they'd ever seen they loved it
and it's all about that inclusion thing
and
that's when i know new this is it this
this is what we need to do initially
self-funded and now with the help of
donations mclinden has created hundreds
of moments like these i've never seen
that i've never seen it
what is it
and i think i can ride that for kaya
it's a stride toward independence
what's it like for you when you see that
moment when the child sees his or her
bike it's everything it's what life is
about later in the day bike number 431
is going
who
to
neurological issues including cerebral
palsy
built to suit each child's needs the
cycles cost several thousand dollars
it
out of reach for many families strained
by medical bills from multiple doctors
and medications
i think it will help strengthen his legs
his core
and just build his muscles
let him just be a kid the things that i
get to see with these families and these
children
is a gift it's an absolute gift and it's
not lost on me and i'm very grateful for
it and subsequently i'll do this forever
a set of wheels but for all it offers
children like max it might as well be a
pair of wings
thank you for cbs mornings i'm janet
chamleon in shreveport louisiana
beautiful piece oh it's beautiful that
is awesome isn't that amazing
those children in their eyes and they're
running to the bike i mean not just like
what's this literally the purest joy
there yeah a child you know riding their
bike for the first time but these kids
yeah these disabilities and it serves
almost as a rehab it does i hope there
are a few more under the christmas tree
for some kids out there yes yes
i want to get involved with something
like that